Tim y sus cofundadores lanzaron una empresa
con USD 2 millones de capital.
Un año después, ya no tenían fondos.
Muchas empresas fracasan en ese punto, pero Tim eligió pelear.
Agotó 11 tarjetas de crédito y acumuló seis cifras en deudas personales
y aún no fue suficiente.
Durante dos años, cada día de pago se plantó frente a sus empleados
y les pidió que sacrificaran sus salarios,
y funcionó.
Más de 50 personas concedieron USD 2 millones,
y ahora, más de una década después,
Pandora vale mil millones.
Cuando crees que hay una forma
de sortear lo que tienes ante ti,
que rendirse no es una opción,
puedes superar obstáculos enormes.
Lo que nos lleva a la lección número 2:
Sacrifica tu ego y deja el complejo de superioridad.
Esto da miedo.
Es el reconocimiento de necesidad o falibilidad.
Tal vez es incluso admitir
que no somos tan especiales como nos gustaría pensar.
Stephanie Forrester de "The Bold and the Beautiful"
pensaba que era bastante especial.
Pensaba que era tan especial,
que no necesitaba mezclarse con la chusma del valle
y se aseguró de que Brooke lo supiera.
Pero tras casi 25 años de batalla épica,
Stephanie se enfermó y dejó entrar a Brooke.
Hicieron las paces,
las archienemigas se hicieron almas gemelas
y Stephanie murió en brazos de Brooke,
y aquí está el mensaje.
Deja el ego.
La vida no se trata de ti.
Es sobre nosotros
y nuestra habilidad para experimentar felicidad
y amor, y mejorar nuestra realidad
llega sólo al ser también vulnerables
y aceptamos la responsabilidad por nuestras acciones
y nuestras no acciones,
como Howard Schultz, el CEO de Starbucks.
Luego de una gran carrera como CEO,
Howard dejó el cargo en 2000,
y Starbucks se desencarriló rápidamente
y las acciones cayeron.
Howard se reincorporó al equipo en 2008,
y una de las primeras cosas que hizo
fue disculparse ante los 180 000 empleados.
Se disculpó.
Y luego, a cambio, pidió ayuda, honestidad e ideas.
Y Starbucks ha más que duplicado
sus ingresos netos desde que Howard volvió.
Así que sacrifica tu deseo de estar acertado o seguro todo el tiempo.
No ayuda a nadie, y menos a ti.
Sacrifica tu ego.
Lección número 3 de telenovela:
La evolución es real.
No se supone que seas un personaje estático.
En televisión, estático es aburrido, y aburrido es despedido.
Se supone que los personajes crecen y cambian.
Bien, en TV, esos cambios dinámicos
pueden llevar a transiciones duras,
en particular cuando ayer un personaje lo interpretaba una persona
y hoy lo interpreta otra.
Los cambios de reparto suceden todo el tiempo en las telenovelas.
En los últimos 20 años,
cuatro actrices interpretaron el mismo papel protagónico
de Carly Benson en "General Hospital".
Cada rostro nuevo generaba un cambio en la vida y personalidad del personaje.
Siempre hubo un pedacito esencial de Carly allí,
pero el personaje y la historia se adaptaron a quien la interpretaba.
Y esto es lo que significa para nosotros.
Aunque no podemos cambiar de rostro en nuestras vidas,
nosotros también podemos evolucionar.
Podemos elegir pintarnos un círculo alrededor de los pies y quedarnos allí,
o podemos abrirnos a las oportunidades,
como Carly, quien pasó de estudiante de enfermería a dueña de hotel,
o como Julia Child.
Julia era una espía en la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
y cuando terminó la guerra, se casó y se mudó a Francia,
y decidió probar con la escuela de cocina.
Julia, sus libros y programas de TV revolucionaron la cocina estadounidense.
Todos tenemos el poder de comenzar el cambio en nuestras vidas,
de evolucionar y adaptarnos.
Nosotros elegimos,
pero a veces la vida lo elige por nosotros y nadie nos avisa previamente.
La sorpresa nos golpea en el rostro.
Quedas en el piso sin aire
y necesitas que te resuciten.
Gracias a Dios tenemos la lección número 4 de telenovela:
La resurrección es posible.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
En 1983, Stefano DiMera de "Days of Our Lives" murió de un ataque cardíaco,
pero en realidad no, porque en 1984
murió cuando se le averió el auto en el puerto,
y volvió en 1985 con un tumor cerebral.
(Risas)
Pero antes de que el tumor lo matara,
Marlena le disparó, y murió al caerse de una pasarela.
Y así sucedió por 30 años.
(Risas)
Aún cuando vimos el cuerpo,
sabíamos la verdad.
Por algo lo llaman el Fénix.
Y ésto es lo que significa para nosotros.
Siempre que el show este al aire,
o tú todavía respires,
nada es permanente.
La resurrección es posible.
Por supuesto, como en la vida,
las telenovelas en algún momento llegan al gran final.
CBS canceló mi show, "As The World Turns" en diciembre de 2009,
y filmamos el último episodio
en junio de 2010.
Fueron seis meses de muerte
y seguí en el tren hasta chocar la montaña.
Y aunque estábamos en medio de una enorme recesión
y millones de personas luchaban por conseguir trabajo,
pensé que de algún modo todo estaría bien.
Así que empaqué a mis hijos y el departamento en Brooklyn
y me mudé con mis suegros
a Alabama.
(Risas)
Tres meses después, nada estaba bien.
Fue cuando vi la emisión del último episodio
y me di cuenta de que el show no era la única fatalidad.
Yo también lo era.
Era desempleada y vivía en el segundo piso
de la casa de mis suegros,
y eso es suficiente para sentirse muerta por dentro.
(Risas)
Pero sabía que mi historia no había terminado,
que no podía terminar.
Sólo tenía que aprovechar todo lo que había aprendido de las novelas.
Tenía que ser valiente como Érica y no rendirme,
así que todos los días, decidí pelear.
Tenía que ser vulnerable como Stephanie
y sacrificar mi ego.
Tuve que pedir ayuda muchas veces en muchos estados.
Tenía que ser adaptable como Carly
y desarrollar mis habilidades, mi actitud y mis circunstancias,
y luego tenía que ser perseverante, como Stefano,
y resucitarme a mí y a mi carrera
como el ave fénix de sus cenizas.
Al final tuve una entrevista.
Tras 15 años en noticias y entretenimiento,
nueve meses de desempleo
y esta entrevista,
me ofrecieron un trabajo de principiante.
Tenía 37 años
y había vuelto de la muerte.
Todos experimentaremos algo que parece un final,
y podemos elegir convertirlo en un comienzo.
Como Tina, que milagrosamente sobrevivió la cascada
y como odio los finales en suspenso,
Tina y Cord sí se divorciaron,
pero volvieron a casarse tres veces antes de que cancelaran el show en 2012.
Así que recuerden,
mientras todavía respiren,
nunca es tarde para cambiar su historia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)